The joe rogan experience.
I much more like Brock because I remember when Frank Mir describe rock on top of
him.
He was like,
it was like a car that was slowly and been onto him and he couldn't push it off
and you're like,
you know,
imagine a bears on you.
You're just like sitting there like,
dude,
it's got my shoulder blade and it's just knowing that my shoulder blade and I'm,
I know I'm going to die.
Nothing you can do.
Holy Fuck.
Do you think you would,
the adrenaline would kick in where you wouldn't feel the pain or do you think it
would be the most horrible fucking,
he definitely wouldn't feel it.
You'd feel it.
It would hurt,
but you would be so terrified of death and you'd be so overwhelmed with all
these fucking neurochemicals to be flying through your synapses.
You'd be out of your mind.
You feel like the pressure that it's happening.
You had,
you had there,
there'd be so much adrenaline.
You'd be in another dimension before you knew it.
That's probably,
that seems like the worst way to die.
There's a guy who got bit real bad and came back and had a video.
He did a selfie and talked about what happened.
He was just walking,
hiking down a trail,
scouting and he came across to um,
female grizzly and her cubs,
which is the worst scenario.
A male grizzly doesn't really,
unless he's really old and it's really late in the season.
Usually they'll just get the fuck away from you,
but the females will fuck you up.
And this female fucked him up and tore his scalp right off of his skull and he
had it like packed down with a baseball hat,
like try to try to hold it in place and his arm snapped and he had big bite
marks in his arm.
But this guy was like a Montana dude,
like the Montana tough.
So he's like,
well vitals are intact.
It might be broken.
I don't know what's going on up there.
Cold Shit.
Fucking yoga teacher and ally.
Okay.
Do you
see,
oh my God.
Looked down his head.
The grizzly with two cubs.
Ha You Kiki.
You barely see,
but the right side of his ear,
his head is basically ripped apart.
I'll save my watch though.
He put the hat on to make himself like,
you know my Christ.
Fucking kidding.
Yet she never got my daddy's watch drove himself to a hospital after walking
three miles to his car.
That's a fucking man.
I'll,
I'll be damned if I'm not going to get the gosh darn best Facebook live video
out of this.
Literally all look at the size of the hole in it's,
Oh my God,
mother,
Fuck.
He's smiling in the picture because he's a fucking Montana dude.
There are different humans.
Do you remember the famous the bear with the karate suit guy and he just fucking
knocks out the lady
specials?
You have a joke about that.
He remembers that.
He's the barrier.
Tears his bitch apart.
It's horrible.
And the other guy with the karate uniforms tribe
decided out of nowhere.
Yes,
sure.
He just decided out of nowhere that he's going to fuck that lady up
and nobody feels bad because you put a fucking party.
Had I met bear trying to do man,
that ain't working.
Yeah,
that's simple.
Simple as that.
Um,
I'm scared of animals do it and now that I have a kid too,
like I'm getting my,
here it is.
This is the video.
Gutterati and bed sits down.
Oh,
this is fine.
Who's this bitch?
The size of the thing.
Like look at the power in it when it grabs her launch.
Imagine how terrified she must've been and everyone's slapping it,
bitch slapping it.
The host is even getting in there.
Why would the host get in there?
Are you crazy
dudes wrestling with a bear
that is Russian.
He's that good.
Ticketek that guy has to be rushed and look at the power in his fucking gay
teen.
He's almost got the bear.
He's almost got the bear out.
Jesus Christ.
This is so crazy in the bear.
Still holding onto that person.
Pass fucking that personnel also,
not even the hardest day of her life in Russia.
Oh my God.
She mean she must've got fucked up by that bear dude.
I mean really fucked up.
The bear didn't use great technique to get out of the gear teeth,
but we just kind of powered out of it.
The only thing that saved her life is that that bear had a muzzle on.
I love that he looks at her like she said something offensive bullies,
you can't predict.
And that's a brown bear that's similar to a grizzly bear.
Probably the Russian version of a brown bear.
They'd have big ass bears over there.
Yeah.
Fuck that dude.
Fuck bears,
dude.
I've,
I saw a real grizzly bear in the wild and it wasn't that far away.
There was like 30 40 yards and looked me in the eyes and I remember thinking,
Whoa,
that's a different look.
He went,
Oh shit.
That's Joe Rowe wasn't even a big one.
It was only like a six foot tall grizzly,
which is not a big grizzly,
but it looked to me,
it looked it,
they look through you like,
what am I gonna do?
Am I gonna eat you?
What am I doing?
Is this safe to safe?
They have to lay low.
The brain's calculate.
Do you have a weapon on you or you have two shotguns and two bows and arrows,
but still,
I'd probably take a while to shotguns and one bone arrow.
I got Sean.
You got my test?
Yeah.
Yes,
it would take a while.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not that easy.
It's a big animal.
Even a six foot one is probably probably 300 pounds.
I mean,
it's a big animal,
but it's the way they look at you.
That's different.
Like I've,
I've seen black bears in the wild.
They look at you like,
what are you,
what's going on over here?
What's happening?
Grizzlies look right through you.
They look right through you.
It's a weird look.
It's a weird like dead look like there's no fear of you at all.
Like what do I do here?
They just trying to figure out whether or not you're a meal.
You're just wandering.
Imagine being a 300 pound animal that just has to wander around looking for shit
to eat.
Welcome to the life of big jail.
I swear to you,
I was gonna say,
can you please stop describing wild animals dimensions.
I've been in life.
I mean,
this is a fucking crazy bear.
Like you see this thing come in and run because it will eat.
You are human beings.
Hundred pounds.
That's coming at you.
All you can do is put it down,
put it in his gut,
their misery.
I said,
animal 300 pounds that is hungry,
imaginary,
no stores.
Looking for hunters to the slipping people at limps.
It just like a,
well,
we,
um,
I was with my friend Jen,
she's a guide and she smacked a fucking tree with this stick.
She picked up the stick and crack this fucking tree and screamed and I screamed
and we cocked our shotguns and that thing took off.
Okay.